welcome to this video playing attention
lost a link and moose link bus from
Belgium ital tengo ring gua that's one
of the best Belgium players about 2,500
and over the Boches okay and get a Zima
SH Kings Indian prolly or maybe is
trying to give this special flavor with
no no hang with nighty to see three okay
i'm playing a somewhat outdated set up
with with this year well okay a 60s got
c5 this idea okay still play that it
should still lead to interesting play be
five is the idea the main reply here c4
c5 yeah okay yeah i will play c5 later
trying to get to a benoni type of
structure maybe maybe no not sure about
the timing white can also just take can
also just stayed now this might be
tricky
not rock do you one coming I don't have
a very good coordination hear something
to defy fsm is a constant variable now
it's not very convenient
yeah can I take can I take here take on
Batum it's probably not greater takes
Queen takes bishop between us also
bishop e6 all the time and I'm not
really good when I came what exactly is
he threatening not that much maybe
I'm should ji-hye reserve is problem
okay maybe I do that after all queen is
introducing rock t 7 is not not a big
problem here thought maybe as soon as
look and play dad and night c 5 being
the defense but now a success hanging
out yeah this I actually thought might
still be viable with this might be
nectar but he can probably just take all
before right no didn't check that hmmmm
I didn't think that this was so terrible
but maybe I'm misjudging things
I'm going to play rookie too well then
probably just win the pawn well not for
not just for nothing but I'm exchange a
pawns that's interesting reply right
guess I can take here right
I probably will check in play Bishop a6
ruka for rookie to rugae six is four
against three okay this is so yeah this
should should be drawn but of course he
can still can continue with two minutes
more on the clock check I was a bit
surprised that he went for that with the
other continuation he had real winning
chances and he can only win on time
basically unless I'm wondering something
check
time Jenny yeah this is know who really
totally drawn after five check check and
King age five I get into g4 and just win
a pawn why can I can shake him forever
check check check I can t some of it
check stalemate yeah this was a very bad
position out of the opening for I mean
wow this was really not great I normally
play this on the white side so I'm
reassuring that it should be quite good
for might um yeah I already don't know
this does not look very attractive now
this yeah yeah here it took a long long
thing but I didn't really find anything
too great I'm not sure how bad it really
is but it was very very young
uncomfortable to play the computer once
play Knight f6 which I didn't really
consider but this looks in fact quite
decent Bishop g5 is
to really a problem I can take him and
catch something like that i'm going to
have some direct threat Sam maybe this
is enough activity possible yeah well I
was hoping for for this for this year
that was really surprised that he hear
hear that you didn't take on took on
before this looks looks pretty obvious
and good for white it's just a pawn
basically okay he took catch up here
which is also upon but they thought that
this is less pressure yeah and here this
is really mysterious why he took on a
form because well this is really just a
draw and the rook c8 and then taking on
a six it's still something going here
Roxy seven having additional pieces on
the board is just helpful my night it's
not a really good piece so I wonder
really why didn't do that this is just a
flat-out draw I mean no no winning
chance whatsoever with my rookie
especially being active on the on the
second rank so it's just nothing
happening like important does this move
h5 that I get this in so it helps me to
exchange pawns which is of course what I
want to do and other than that like just
stays active and wait such proceedings
it's really not much that that white
white can do ya hear f5 is just a check
check check direct role check check
check I could have could have changed
already but
okpe got this symbolic advantage of the
porn but of course it's just a draw okay
thanks for watching